on friday we told you about a character
in washington called frank
luntz once lobbies he's not a registered
lobbyist but
he lobbies on behalf of some of the
world's most left-wing corporations
a lot of people do that here's the
interesting thing about frank luntz at
the same time he's doing that he
also advises the leadership of the
republican party
so frank luntz works for google and nike
and delta airlines among many others
several years ago frank luntz advised
the makers of oxycontin
on how to blame rural americans as
thousands of young people in rural
america
drop dead of opioid ods franklins did
that
so he's not someone that normal people
would go to for advice and if you were
running the republican party you
definitely wouldn't because frank luntz
is effectively a democrat
we know this because we've listened to
him now once typically launders his own
opinions through the pseudo-scientific
focus groups that he conducts but in
real life
his views make no mistake bear no
resemblance whatsoever to the views of
actual republican voters
so again the question is how did someone
like this
wind up with so much influence in the
republican
party why do republican officials listen
more carefully to
frank luntz than they listen to their
own voters
that is a mystery a lot of people have
asked that question in washington and as
of three days ago
here was our best guess for why
so why does frank luntz remain a fixture
in republican politics
at a time when the companies he works
for are opposed to the republican party
explicitly so well in part because he is
particularly close to the house minority
leader kevin mccarthy
of california and has been since
mccarthy entered politics
in an interview earlier this year lunch
described kevin mccarthy as a personal
friend
and that relationship gives frank lund's
outsized
influence over the republican party's
policy positions
so lunz is a personal friend of kevin
mccarthy's who's the top-ranking
republican in the house
that's what we said turns out we didn't
know the half of it
over the weekend we got a call from a
source who said that in fact
frank luntz and kevin mccarthy are not
simply friends
they're roommates kevin mccarthy lives
in frank luntz's apartment in downtown
washington
that's what we were told and honestly we
did not believe it the top republican in
the house
lives with a google lobbyist come on
come on even by the sleazy and corrupt
standards of politics in washington that
did not seem possible in fact it sounded
like a joke
but this morning since we heard it we
called to check with kevin mccarthy's
spokeswoman and when we raised this she
all but
chuckled at the suggestion no when he's
in washington she told us kevin mccarthy
rents hotel rooms
or sleeps in his office in the capitol
he certainly isn't living with frank
once
okay and that seemed logical to us but
we did press a little bit because we got
the tip from someone we consider
reliable and we just wanted to be sure
so the spokeswoman said she would get
back to us
two hours later we got this text quote
following up on our conversation from
earlier today
because of the pandemic mccarthy has
rented a room in washington
at a fair market price from frank
once so actually the top republican in
the house
does live with someone who lobbies for
google mystery soft
not only are they friends they're
roommates
so now you know why they listen to frank
luntz
but they don't listen to you no matter
how cynical you become lately watching
washington that's still a pretty
remarkable thing to learn
but other questions remain for example
what did the coronavirus pandemic
have to do with kevin mccarthy's choice
of apartments the chinese unleash a
virus on the world
and all of a sudden congressional
leaders have to live with frank luntz
was there cdc guidance on that if so we
missed it
if anything covett increased the number
of housing options in washington dc
in some places apartment prices fell but
not in frank luntz's building
frank luntz lives in one of the most
expensive buildings in washington we
pulled the deed and we checked
the estimate that we found shows that
lunz's condo in the fashionable pen
quarter part of the city would likely
rent for over
5 000 a month that's the quote fair
market price
so the question is is kevin mccarthy
paying five
thousand dollars every month to frank
luntz to live in his house
we would love to know the answer we
asked several times of his office and no
one got back to us with an answer
if kevin mccarthy isn't paying market
price
he is likely violating house ethics
rules on taking gifts
and someday we have no doubt we will
find out exactly what he is paying
but no matter what he's paying as far as
we're concerned the price of the
apartment
is not the crime here kevin mccarthy's
real crime
is mocking his voters kevin mccarthy
promises republicans he shares their
values
he tells them he's on their side he says
that he will
fight for them against permanent
washington the forces that would like to
destroy their lives
voters believe kevin mccarthy when he
says this they send him back to office
every two years
they send him money and at the end of
the day kevin mccarthy goes home to
frank luntz's apartment in pen quarter
and he laughs about it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else